TO THAT STATE WIDE ELECTION.
WE'LL TELL YOU WHAT THAT IS IN
JUST A MINUTE.
FIRST UP, FOR THE SECOND TIME IN
LIVING MEMORY THERE'S AN
ELECTION RECOUNT CRISIS IN THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
JUST LAST WEEK REPUBLICANS RICK
SCOTT AND RON DESANTIS DEFEATED
BILL NELSON AND ANDREW GILLUM IN
THE SENATE AND GUBERNATORIAL
RACES.
YET JUST SIX DAYS LATER, IT IS
VERY POSSIBLE THAT BOTH THOSE
DEMOCRATS WILL WIN THE SEATS,
THE ONES THAT JUST THE OTHER DAY
THEY HAD LOST.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN, EXACTLY?
WELL, THOUSANDS OF NEW AND
UNCOUNTED BALLOTS APPEARED IN
FLORIDA, MOSTLY IN
DEMOCRATICALLY NAMED COUNTIES.
THOSE BALLOTS CHANGED THE
RESULTS SUFFICIENTLY TO TRIGGER
A STATE WIDE RECOUNT.
THE RECOUNT IS UNDER WAY RIGHT
NOW.
THE PROCESS SO FAR IS NOT
INSPIRING CONFIDENCE IN THE
SYSTEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS COMPLAINED
ABOUT IT, AS HAVE PLENTY OTHER
PEOPLE.
BUT IT TURNS OUT COMPLAINING
ABOUT THIS IS NOT ALLOWED, SO TO
RESTATE THE RULES, IN CASE
YOU'VE FORGOTTEN.
WHEN A REPUBLICAN WINS AN
ELECTION, IT IS FINE TO QUESTION
THE LEGITIMACY OF THE PROCESS.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN DOING THAT
SINCE THE VERY DAY TRUMP WAS
ELECTED.
THAT IS PATRIOTIC.
IT'S YOUR DUTY.
BUT WHEN THE DEMOCRATIC POWER IS
AT STAKE, RAISING ANY QUESTION
ABOUT THE PROCESS, IT'S WRONG.
NOTHING LESS THAN THE ROAD TO
DICTATORSHIP.
WATCH.
>> HE'S BASICALLY TRYING TO
UNDER MIND AT EVERY TURN.
IT'S NOT JUST FLORIDA.
HE WEIGHED IN ON ARIZONA.
HE'S WEIGHED IN ON OTHER RACES.
HE'S UNDER MINDING THE
LEGITIMACY OF ELECTIONS.
>> WHERE HE DOESN'T LIKE THE
RESULTS.
THAT IS A HALL MARK OF A FAILING
DEMOCRACY.
OF SOMEONE MOVING TOWARD
AUTHORITARIAN.
>> HE'S AUTHORITARIAN, SCREAMED
THE AUTHORITARIAN.
DEFENDING THE RESULTS OF
ELECTIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CALLED IS NOT THE SAME AS
OVERTURNING ELECTIONS.
LISTEN TO THE INCOMING HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI EXPLAIN HOW
THIS WORKS.
>> PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SAYING
THERE'S ELECTION FRAUD IN
FLORIDA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS HAPPENING
IN BROWARD COUNTY?
>> MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
PRESIDENT IS ANY TIME HE CHARGES
SOMEBODY WITH SOMETHING, HE'S
PROJECTING WHAT HE MIGHT HAVE
DONE HIMSELF.
WE ARE NOT --
>> ELECTION FRAUD?
>> OBSTRUCTION, SUPPRESSION OF
THE VOTE.
>> Tucker: SUPPRESSION.
NANCY PELOSI DID NOT USE THAT
WORD ACCIDENTALLY.
THE TERM IS USED TO EVOKE IMAGES
OF A TIME OF NIGHT RIDERS AND
BURNING CROSSES.
A TIME VERY FEW LIVING AMERICANS
REMEMBER PERSONALLY BUT THAT
LIVES IN OUR COLLECTIVE MEMORY.
THIS KIND OF TALK CAN BE
POLITICALLY USEFUL.
THAT'S WHY THEY DO IT.
THAT'S WHY IT'S A THEME ON THE
LEFT.
IN BROWARD COUNTY, BALLOT
COUNTING IS OVERSEEN BY A WOMAN
CALLED BRENDA SNIPES PF SHE WAS
PREVIOUSLY CAUGHT ILLEGALLY
DESTROYING BALLOTS.
THIS TIME SHE'S MIXED INVALID
BALLOTS WITH VALID ONES.
THAT SOUNDS BAD.
BUT DON'T DARE CRITICIZE SNIPES
FOR THE WAY SHE DOES HER JOB.
ACCORDING TO MSNBC, THE ONLY
RELEVANT FACT ABOUT BRENDA
SNIPES IS THE COLOR OF HER SKIN.
WATCH.
>> HERE IS THE WAY THEY ARE
TREATING BRYNN TKA SNIPES WHO IS
AN OLDER BLACK WOMAN IN THE DEEP
SOUTH.
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS YOU WATCH
THIS VIDEO.
>> LOCK HER UP!
LOCK HER UP!
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE PERSON, IN
THIS CASE A WOMAN INVOLVED, SHE
HAS HAD A HORRIBLE HISTORY.
>> Tucker: SO IN CASE YOU'RE
WONDERING WHAT DEMAGOGRY LOOKS
LIKE?
YOU HAVE JUST SEEN IT.
DEMOCRATS ARE ACTING LIKE THEY
HAVE BEEN ROBBED OF POWER.
YET JUST IN ELECTIONS, DEMOCRATS
GAINED POWER.
THEY RETOOK THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AFTER EIGHT
YEARS.
THEY NEARLY BROKE EVEN IN THE
SENATE.
THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH THOUGH.
THEY WANT MORE.
THEY WILL USE ANY MEANS
NECESSARY TO GET IT.
IN PALM BEACH COUNTY, THE
CANVASSING BOARD DISQUALIFIED A
VOTE BECAUSE IT WAS CAST BY A
NONCITIZEN.
NONCITIZENS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
VOTE.
IT IS ILLEGAL.
ALSO NEVER HAPPENS IN THIS
COUNTRY EVER!
WE'RE TOLD THAT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES IS RACIST.
BUT IN THIS CASE, IT ACTUALLY
DID HAPPEN.
NOBODY DISPUTES THAT.
DEMOCRATS RESPONSE TO THIS
HAPPENING, ATTORNEYS FOR GILLUM
AND NELSON SAID THE VOTE SHOULD
NOT BE DISQUALIFIED.
THEY OBJECTED TO
DISQUALIFICATION.
ONLY THING THAT MATTERS TO THEM
IN THE END IS WINNING.
IT'S EASY TO FIND YOURSELF
THINKING LIKE THIS IF YOU
BELIEVE POLITICS IS HOLY WAR.
RELIGIOUS TRAOEPBLGSISTS AN
ELECTION IS NOT A CONTEST
BETWEEN FELLOW AMERICANS WHO
DISAGREE ON POLICY, IT IS A
BATTLE BETWEEN GOOD AND EVIL.
EVIL MUST BE VANQUISHED AT ALL
COSTS NO MATTER WHAT.
GILLIBRAND REACHED THIS
CONCLUSION.
SENATOR GILLIBRAND IS NOTED AN
OBVIOUS CANNED FOR AMERICA'S
LEADING MORAL VOICE.
SHE WAS A LONG TIME DEFENDER OF
HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
BUT LISTEN TO HER NOW PREACHING
LIKE IT'S THE LAST SUNDAY IN
LENT.
>> ARE YOU STAYING IN THE SENATE
OR RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT?
>> I HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
IT.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
PUTTING INTO THIS COUNTRY IS SO
DISTURBING, SO DARK THAT I
BELIEVE THAT I HAVE BEEN CALLED
TO FIGHT AS HARD AS I POSSIBLY
CAN TO RESTORE THAT MORAL
INTEGRITY.
>> SOUNDS LIKE A YES.
>> I'M THINKING ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: MORAL INTEGRITY,
MORAL DECENCY.
THAT IS WORRISOME.
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW DEEPLY
FLAWED THEY ARE TEND NOT TO
OVERREACH.